- [Lecturer] We've already had many videos
on Buddhism and its
connections to Hinduism
but what we want to do in this video
is more explicitly answer
an important question.
Why did Buddhism emerge
when and where it did?
And this is a question that you should
always be asking yourself
as you study history.
Why did something emerge,
why did something happen
when and where it did?
And I encourage you to pause
this video and think about it.
Maybe you're viewing
some of the other videos
on Buddhism and Hinduism or
doing some research yourself.
Well let's remind
ourselves of the context.
Buddha emerges in northeast
India in modern day Nepal
at the end of the Vedic period.
Hinduism has been evolving now
for many hundreds of years,
arguably close to 1,000 years.
Now as we've talked about in other videos,
there's a spiritual core of Hinduism
described in the Upanishads,
this idea of Atman, your inner self.
Brahman, the ultimate reality that we live
in an illusion of Maya
and through meditation
we should be able to pierce that veil
and eventually break
free from the cycle of
birth and rebirth, Samsara,
and become one with Brahmin,
become one with the ultimate reality.
But in the time of Buddha there were
other aspects of Hinduism that were
maybe even more associated
with the religion.
There is also a lot of
ritual in the Vedas,
and in the time of Buddha the
Hinduism that he grows up in
is very focused on the
ritual aspects of it.
And it was a Hinduism
in which not just anyone
could do the rituals, it was
a fairly stratified
society that he grew up in.
We discussed the caste
system in some detail.
It's still a matter of
debate to what degree
caste is hereditary in it's
actually part of the religion,
but it was a fact of
the culture of the time.
Where at the top you had the
Brahmins who were the priests
and much of their power came from
their ability to interpret the Vedas.
Came from their exclusive ability
to practice the rituals just right.
Buddha came from a ruling class,
he came from the Kshatriyas class,
but even they were considered
one notch below the Brahmins
and especially the bottom
rungs of the caste system
these were fairly marginalized people.
And so when Buddha emerges,
initially in a very privileged life
he's essentially a prince
but eventually when Buddha sees
the suffering in the world,
a lot of the suffering happening in these
lower rungs of society,
he looks for answers,
spiritual answers, and is not
satisfied by what he sees.
He's not satisfied by the answers
that he's getting from this ruling class.
You could imagine that
he's even suspicious of it,
whether they're focused on
the true spiritual core,
or whether they're focused on ritual
as a way to keep their power.
But there's also another
tradition in Hinduism at the time.
This is all very important to why
Buddhism was able to
emerge when it happened.
There was this tradition of asceticism,
of people going off into the woods
and meditating and thinking
about the nature of life
and these folks were much more focused
on this spiritual core and so Buddha
initially takes that track.
He goes and he meditates and he eventually
comes to a realization,
he awakens so to speak
at the root of Buddhism is that there
should not be this stratified society.
That one should not focus on ritual.
That at the end of the day, you need
to have a very personal path to Nirvana,
to escaping the cycle of Samsara.
So I would argue, if I were
to simply answer the question
why did Buddhism emerge
when and where it did?
Well if you consider Buddhism to be
a reformation of Hinduism,
it's important that Buddha was Hindu.
It's also important that
it needed to be reformed
or at least Buddha thought
it needed to be reformed.
So it's important that at
the time that he lived,
Hinduism had become very ritualistic.
It had become very stratified,
and he saw a need to reform it.
Now there's even a further question.
It emerged when it did and we have
some ideas of why that
might have happened,
but why did it become a major religion?
One argument was that what he was
describing was just very compelling.
You no longer have to go
through this ruling class,
through the priests anymore.
You could have your own personal path.
It was also perhaps compelling to people
who felt marginalized in the
traditional hierarchy of the time.
Another argument would
be the emperor Ashoka
who we study in other videos,
that once he converts to Buddhism
after feeling guilty
for his war with Kalinga
where tens of thousands if not
hundreds of thousands
of people are killed,
he converts to Buddhism and becomes
a major patron of Buddhism and sends
missionaries throughout
the world to spread it.
So one argument of why Buddhism spread
is that a few hundred years after Buddha
you have a significant powerful emperor
converting to the religion
and deciding to spread it.
Now that leads us to a second question.
Are there other historical parallels
to what we have just described?
And this is something that once again
you should always ask yourself in history.
And what's the structure of this?
Well there's some spiritual core here,
but eventually you have
the ritualistic side
as it actually gets practiced.
And you have a stratified society
where you have a class that has
a bit of a monopoly on the ritual
derives a lot of their
power from that ritual.
And then someone comes
along and says wait,
this priesthood is more
focused on power and on ritual
than the true spiritual
core, and they're not happy
with the answers that that
priesthood is delivering.
Can you think of any
other parallels to that?
Well a few come to my mind,
and once again these could all be debated
and that's the fun thing about history.
I encourage you to debate
all of these things.
About 500 years after the time of Buddha,
someone by the name of Jesus of Nazareth
comes onto the scene.
Where is the parallel?
Well you have the
spiritual core of Judaism
that comes from Abraham and Moses,
but then you have the ritual
of the Pharisees of the time.
They are the power brokers.
He feels that the religion is corrupted.
He sees the money changers in the temple,
and much of his preaching
is a reformation,
a reminder of that spiritual core.
He also tries to encourage people
to have a more personal connection
and tries to break up the stratification
and once again, you could imagine this
to be a very compelling message
for those who felt marginalized
and the parallel goes even further.
Just as Buddha had Ashoka
come onto the scene
a few hundred years after Buddha
to really popularize the religion,
Jesus has a parallel.
Roughly 300 years after the life of Jesus,
Constantine is emperor of the Romans.
The same Romans who have
been persecuting Christians
for 300 years, and all
of the sudden Constantine
not only allows it to be legal,
but he eventually promotes the religion
and converts to the
religion and it eventually,
after Constantine's death,
becomes the official religion of Rome
whether you're talking
about Buddha or Jesus
you have a reformer and then
a few hundred years later
you have a powerful emperor who
adopts the religion and spreads it.
What are other examples?
Well even within the world of Christianity
we can fast forward another 1,500 years
from the time of Jesus and go
to the time of Martin Luther.
Who at least from his perspective
sees the Christian church
in the early 16th Century
and thinks that it has diverged
from the spiritual core,
from the teachings of Jesus
that it has become too focused on ritual,
that the priesthood and
the papacy is really
more about power than it
is about spirituality.
So he brings about what will be known
as a Protestant Reformation
which is making the
religion more personal,
not have to go through a priest,
having a personal connection
with the spiritual core of religion.
After this video think about
other historical parallels.
Are there other religions?
What about Islam?
What about Sikhism?
How do they connect to these ideas
or how do they not connect to these?
Maybe they're counter-examples,
and maybe there are parallels in history
that have nothing to do with religion.
Maybe it's more about politics
or science or economics.
Think about these questions.